yves on est là tout près de la frontière
avec la russie et c'est roméo langlois
que l'on retrouve pour france24 bonjour
rom et/ou vous venez d'arriver dans la
ville que se passe-t-il sur place
à bien écouter oui nous venons d'arriver
à kharkiv dès notre arrivée nous avons
pu entendre des explosions l'os au nord
de la ville régulière toute la journée
il ya des explosions à kharkiv il ya eu
au moins 50 frappe russe aujourd'hui n'a
pas encore de bilan kharkiv est
considéré par beaucoup comme une cité
martyre après mario paul sur sur la cote
plus au sud qui a été totalement rasée
par l'artillerie russe et bien kharkiv
la deuxième ville du pays et
probablement et même certainement la
ville qui est le plus sous le feu de
l'artillerie russe alors je me trouve
actuellement devant un mouvement
symbolique que vous pouvez voir juste
derrière moi il s'agit du siège du
conseil régional qui a été attaqué au
tout début de l'invasion russe cette
attaque avait été célèbre dans le monde
entier car elle avait été filmée par une
caméra de sécurité et tout le monde
avait été marqué par la violence de la
frappe donc dans la mode pouvait voir ce
qu'il reste du vieux beijing qui a été
considérablement endommagée vingt-cinq
personnes environ avaient été tués lors
de cette frappe et des prix dans les
bombardements n'ont pas cessé les jours
les plus intenses il ya au moins cent
frappe par jour nous entendons de
manière permanente notamment dans la
zone nord des des explosions des
déflagrations il y à de très nombreuses
victimes impossible pour l'instant
d'avoir un chiffre exact car une grande
partie des victimes sont encore sous les
décombres mais on parle d'au moins 300
morts peut être beaucoup plus faut
savoir que à la morgue les corps
s'entassent et 300 mans et bien sûr
beaucoup plus de blessés merci beaucoup
pour ce point romeo langlois avec
catherine norris trent à kharkiv